in the heart of the strip you can't miss
its neon signs and packed parking lot
located off Las Vegas Boulevard and
Convention Center Drive the Peppermill
Restaurant is a testament of its time
still standing in its original location
which was once surrounded by big name
casinos like the Stardust and the
Riviera the Peppermill opened its doors
December 26 1972 and has become a
favorite staple for many over the years
once inside you're transported back in
time with its retro but modern day decor
and Fireside Lounge which has served as
a backdrop in numerous films and TV
shows such as casino and Giada at home
executive chef Nicholas orth says
there's a place for everybody from
locals to tourists and celebrities such
as Floyd Mayweather and Chris Angel just
to name a few my dad's worked here
uncles named every member of my family
has worked here previously in the past
so pepper Mill's in my blood so this
place celebrating 50 years of just an
amazing experience for my family and
everybody else also known for its huge
portions of food and unique atmosphere
locals like Harry Spiro keep coming back
for the Nostalgia I've been coming here
for 47 years
and uh first time I came here was 1975
and I had a Denver omelette and 47 years
later I had another Denver album I
brought my kids with me so show them the
history of this place uh this place
hasn't changed the waitresses are still
wearing the same uniforms gonna keep
bringing them here and my grandkids Sage
skate evader from San Diego also brings
his family and friends every time they
visit it's really fun environment the
food is great and really get a feel of
Las Vegas with a lot of the personal
touches uh waitresses seem like they're
in a good mood and it's just a fun
atmosphere Chef ort was already
preparing for the next 50 years with new
AC units Cutlery and more he wants to
keep that atmosphere going they have
expectations when they come to the door
this is what I had last time the time
before that time before that I want to
be sure that we make up that we live up
to those expectations
want to celebrate its 50th Pepper Mill
having a party Monday morning at 9 30
cake balloons and food specials and
they're expecting special guests
including Penn and Teller join the
celebration at 9 30 a.m congrats to the
Peppermill a lot of Peppermill fans here
at Channel 8